to the human eye there appears to be a
glowing three-dimensional butterfly
moving around inside this black box in
fact all it is is a tiny polystyrene
bead that's really small yeah
it's like a one millimeter to Namita
with if suspended and we can move it so
fast to create a 3d shape this is a
volumetric display it's an image that
exists in real 3d space and this latest
development in the field is unique in
that it uses sound waves not only to
create the image but also to add audio
and tactile sensations oh yeah you can
feel it's like really Oh like it's kind
of gentle buzzer breeze my name's Lizzie
Gibney and I've come to the University
of Sussex in the UK to see that display
for myself the most surprising thing
about it is that it doesn't look like a
flat projection you can see that it's
really floating there in three
dimensions and in person the image
doesn't flicker like it does on camera
people don't believe it and then there's
this magical moment where they can
evolve that's real the display works by
a process called acoustic levitation in
the walls of this box arrays of speakers
producing sound waves so by using the
sound creating a standing wave and tiny
bead the speaker's create areas of high
pressure that can trap a polystyrene
bead and suspend it in midair moving the
bead around and shining a light on it
creates a glowing moving dot move that
door around fast enough and you can
create shapes in the air what we've
created is a Cousteau phoretic
volumetric display so we basically use
sound to trap
a lightweight object in free space and
we can update its position at very high
update rates so fast that persistence of
vision happens and you think it's a full
object the team was inspired by research
published last year from Brigham Young
University the American group had
successfully created a volumetric
display by steering tiny particles of
cellulose using laser light they were
trapping a particle with lasers and
doing something very similar and for us
to be honest we were not even thinking
that that could be a possibility you
know what we looked at each other I
think we can do that I know that's right
the team at the University of Sussex has
been working on using sound waves to
move small objects or create sensations
for a few years but the big challenge in
creating a volumetric display was to get
the beads moving fast enough that it
appears as a single non moving image
since the other image for human eyes the
whole path for example I got if you want
to create a circle this circle should be
scanned in 100 milliseconds and that so
the beads should be moved so fast you
could create this path in 100
millisecond but I see that's part the
end of it right so because we are
updating at that speed we can also
create audio and tactile feedback so the
object is singing as it's moving because
and at the same time if you bring your
hand close to it you will get a
sensation of touch the researchers can
use the same waves of pressure that
control the bead to create ripples in
the air fluttering on a finger to give a
tactile experience that's something that
no other kind of volumetric display can
do we create that focusing point to
another place for tactile feedback so
it's like a levitation tactile
levitation cocktail so we can switch the
quickly play so fast yes we you don't
see it when you're watching you don't
hear it
it has to make you feel like you're
getting closer to something something
real like batting wings or something and
by using the interactions between
ultrasound waves the display can even
produce audible sound at the moment the
display can only create small simple
shapes but if the team can get their
beads moving even faster or can
manipulate multiple beads they could
create bigger and more complex images
and the team hopes that this could be
the start of 3d displays becoming part
of everyday life
the idea of just 3d content to be
something that's there you go you use it
whenever you need to use it you don't
need to use it you don't or I need to be
seeing that 3d content but also my notes
or just check what time it is you know
like blending the filter content in our
real day-to-day life just in a seamless
manner it's something that's very
valuable this is literally our first
step we've got a long way to go but the
interesting bit is that the fundamentals
that are underpinning this kind of
displays they are strong they can really
deliver all of this and I think that's
very exciting
you